bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur tv fil 78 si vous nous rejoignez
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
la question du soir faut-il obliger les
maires à construire des logements
sociaux
c'est la question à laquelle nous allons
tenter de répondre avec nos invités
n'hésitez pas à réagir sur le twitter de
l'émission hashtag 7,8 société le
ministre de la ville patrick k nerveux
je le cite créer un électrochoc chez les
mères qui me respecte bull qui ne
respectent pas pardon la loi solidarité
et renouvellement urbain petite loi sru
ce texte oblige toutes les communes de
france de plus de 3500 habitants à avoir
un quota de 25 % de logements sociaux
dans un objectif de mixité sociale que
dit vraiment la loi sru
pourquoi certaines villes préfère payer
des pénalités plutôt que de construire
des hlm de quels moyens disposent les
communes pour appliquer la loi
quid des villes qui dépassa largement le
quota de logements sociaux est bien pour
répondre à ces questions quatre invités
autour de la table
nous allons commencer avec nicolas tardy
joubert qui est membre du bureau du
parti chrétien démocrate des idées
noires
nous avons également thomas sur dix qui
est adjoint au maire de trappes à
l'urbanisme bons soins mireille frésil
association solidarité une nouvelle pour
le logement vous n'êtes une membre
active
bon soit il n'avait pas l'air convaincu
bruno sauvage membres du cos skis
bonsoir est avec nous également gilles
bombard qui est doctorant en droit à
l'université de paris xiii et qui nous
accompagne pour cette émission ce sera
notre spécialiste droit et justement
c'est avec gilles c'est avec vous il
qu'on va commencer
est ce que vous pourriez expliquer en
quelques mots aux téléspectatrices et
téléspectateurs en quoi consiste la loi
sru à la loi sru déjà trois lettres
trois lettres qui renvoie à la
solidarité et au renouvellement urbains
pour faire simple il est question là des
logements sociaux c'est une loi qui
fêtera bientôt son 15e anniversaire
puisqu'elle a été votée le 13 décembre
2000 sous le gouvernement
man jospin par les objectifs de la loi
sru son sont claires favoriser la mixité
sociale en instaurant un taux minimum
obligatoire de logements sociaux dans
une commune en fonction et de sa taille
et de sa localisation d'ici 2020 donc
précisément il s'agit d'instaurer 20% de
logements sociaux pour les communes et
en plus de 1500 habitants en ile de
france et 20% de logements sociaux pour
les communes et en plus de 1000 de 3500
habitants dans les autres régions alors
ce taux minimum a été revue à la hausse
par la loi du flou du 18 décembre 2012
on passe de 20 à 25 % de logements
sociaux obligatoires dans certains
secteurs objectifs à remplir à d'ici
2025 alors entre 2011 et 2013
c'est plus de 1000 communes qui étaient
concernés par la loi sru
merci gilles alors messieurs madame
madame frésil également qu'est ce qui
empêche
concrètement les maires aujourd'hui on
va commencer peut-être avec vous on
s'attarde ouvert qu'est ce qui empêche
concrètement amer aujourd'hui de
construire des logements sociaux
alors avant de répondre à cette question
je voudrais faire un petit préalable
dire que effectivement cette loi sru et
le mot solidarité et pour nous le
premier lieu de solidarité c'est la
famille
or ce que l'on constate aujourd'hui
c'est un certain délitement de la
famille davantage de divorce qui aidera
donc il faut faire en sorte que nous
veillions des politiques qui permettent
de ressouder les liens familiaux
c'est la première chose c'est à cause du
logement que les familles se séparent
non non mais quand est remixé par ça
crée un besoin de logements important en
ce moment
ensuite la crise économique fait que
gérer on a avec cinq ou six millions de
personnes au chômage ou en sous-emploi
des difficultés donc a besoin le de
créer du logement social qui est
extrêmement important donc le logement
pour nous ça répond aux besoins
fondamentaux de la personne comme
se nourrir se soigner il faut pouvoir se
loger c'est répond à la dignité de la
personne dans son intégralité
effectivement il faut se rappeler que
tout est lié c'est à dire
qu'effectivement si la famille est uni
n'a pas besoin de la double logement et
donc c'est sûr les il faut traiter les
causes et pas seulement les conséquences
ça c'est la première chose alors sinon
concrètement qu'est ce qui les empêche
qu'est ce qui empêche les maires hommes
ou femmes de construire pour certains
qui ne qui n'atteignent pas ce qu'ils
sont très loin du quota des 20 % et
bientôt des 25% alors je pense que
l'objectif doit être de faire en sorte
que les objectifs donc de construction
soient atteints le problème qu'il faut
deux questions à se poser
la première c'est le foncier est il
disponible ou pas et on sait que bien
souvent on me préserver les centres
villes parce que on veut conserver
conserver le charme et centre-ville mais
il faut trouver des terrains pour
trouver des solutions mais ça pourrait
être tout à fait la proximité de l'iss
et des friches au niveau de la sncf de
la ratp des choses comme ça donc at-on
le foncier des premières questions parce
qu'il ne suffit pas de décréter je veux
c'est pas une décision brutale
il faut quand même trouver les endroits
où les construire et puis ensuite à ton
les capacités financières pour réaliser
ces constructions et notamment ça
retombe bien souvent au niveau des
mairies est donc sacré vraiment des
problèmes majeurs tomasi justement pour
répondre peut-être à ce que je disais à
l'instant nicolas debarge ouvert est ce
que ces problèmes de foncier ou ses
problèmes d'argent sont des problèmes
réels qui empêche les maires bien
construire alors un petit ou contexte
préalable il faut remercier on a besoin
chaque année de 70000 logements
supplémentaires logements sociaux il ya
un retard en france qui est considérable
on sait qu'on a à peu près besoin d'un
million
huit cent mille logements laissés une
estimation à la baisse par rapport aux
vrais besoins
la création de logements supplémentaires
elles mécaniquement créé la baisse de du
coût des loyers donc ça aussi c'est
important de le savoir
et là dessus on a un contexte politique
alors qu'ils émergent par rapport à ces
questions là on entend par exemple
valérie pécresse dire qu'elle
promettrait la fin des subventions aux
villes qui ont plus de 30 % de logements
sociaux pour trappe c'est ce serait
catastrophique c'est à dire qu'on aurait
en pleine rénovation parce que la ville
se régénère un devoir d'arrêt finalement
parce qu'on aurait plus de subventions
c'est peut-être 5% oui voila j'ai
effectivement être à part un historique
particulier j'ai par revenir sur sur
cette histoire mais on a effectivement
la volonté au sein de la ville de créer
une mixité dans cette mixité elle a
commencé déjà avec l'anru la rénovation
urbaine
on le sait il y avait 78 % de logements
sociaux il fait un temps on a descendu à
actuellement à 60% et l'objectif de la
de la mairie ses 55% alors pourquoi 55%
c'est pour une mixité je pense qu'on
aura l'occasion de revenir là dessus et
puis on n'a pas baissé le nombre de
logements sociaux pour autant cette et
mathématiques c'est à dire que dès qu'on
a fait la rénovation urbaine
nous avons créé de l'accession sociale l
accession libre donc on n'a pas baissé
le nombre de logements sociaux les a
simplement accompagné lors de la
rénovation de la construction de
nouveaux logements
ça c'est la chose la deuxième chose
qu'il faut dire c'est que il ya un
objectif quand même pour marion pour
toutes les villes c'est la question du
parcours résidentiel
vous avez un jeune qui quitte le foyer
familial il trouve un premier travail
c'est dans la catégorie il va chercher
forcément la catégorie la moins onéreuse
des hlm à savoir le plh 1 donc on va
rentrer dans les îles se pas se mettre
en couple
je finis avec la métaphore pour
comprendre il va se mettre en couple et
là y verra une augmentation de salaire
et il peut monter en gamme de hlm live a
montré sur un pea lui est grosso modo
ensuite avant d'acheter pourquoi pas un
jour en accession sociale avec le ptz
avec tout ce qu'on sait les aides de
l'état
peut-être qu'il aurait un tremplin avec
un pls voilà on est sur un parcours
enfin parcours c'est ça que qui est
important de comprendre c'est qu'il faut
un parcours dans chaque ville on a des
jeunes et des moins jeunes
parce que la vérité c'est que on a de
plus en plus et c'est le constat de
personnes qui ont plus de 60 ans qu'ils
sont
demandeur est peut-être un chiffre très
important par rapport à ce constat là et
puis vous dire un peu après je pense à
se comprendre comment on peut remédier à
ces questions là c'est de se dire que il
ya en france 70% des ménages qui seront
éligibles aux logements sociaux 70%
tu as fait beau on est souvent dans un
débat un petit peu caricatural qui dit
que le logement social
finalement on va faire venir la pauvreté
au sein des centres villes au sein de
nom les villes savent évolué en leur
temps on peut voir aussi bien trappe
comme à guyancourt comme annie des
quartiers qui sont au centre ville on a
50 % de logements sociaux 50%
d'accession et je vous mets au défi
devant la différence c'est un argument
qui est souvent reprise vous venez de
weezer la pauvreté qui va arriver en
centre-ville beaucoup d'administrés
d'ailleurs les maires le dise clairement
ce ne sont pas les mères qui sont contre
le fait d'avoir des logements sociaux
mais les administrés dans votre nouvelle
pad hlm dans leur ville c'est ça c'est
un exemple à bry sur marne entre 2011 et
2013 0 logements sociaux alors c'est une
catastrophe dans les villages n'offrent
plus de parcours résidentiel c'est ça le
problème
donc on a et le pire c'est que certaines
villes hélas on est dans la politique je
vais le dire franchement des villes de
droite qui ne jouent pas le jeu qui ont
entre 0 et 2 x 3 % qui en plus un
langage un peu les vaches qui revient un
peu langage dogmatique
si on regarde sur l'île de france un
chiffre clé 39 des communes qui ne
respectent pas la loi sru sont sur les
41 39 sur les 40 sont des villes du même
bord de puma nombre les graisses donc
voilà il ya des questions à se poser
le sauvage alors donc je parle au nom de
ce qu'on appelle le codesria de
conseiller développement de saint
quentin en yvelines
alors donc d'organismes et l organisme
consultatif qui résonne à l'échelle des
sept communes de saint quentin en
yvelines
la question que nous pose est donc au
sacre est un jeu fait la moyenne des
sept communes on est aux alentours de 39
% de logement social order 9,9 pour cent
alors qu'ils aiment 40 heures
donc là je dirais on se sent pas très
visés par cette cette injonction
révocation considère que madjer atteint
le niveau mais c'est donc déjà en
prenant sauvage beaucoup puisqu'il ya
une infographie qui arrive
justement à l'écran c'est 39 9% surtout
50 ans a réglé quand on entre dans le
détail
geyer des disparités il ya une commune
qui est en retard un voisin breton nommé
yang 14 % mais qui a quand même je pense
à la volonté de rattraper
progressivement de se rapprocher de du
chiffre donc je pense pas qu'ils aient
d'opposition la loi sru
par contre il ya une disparité entre
communes qui s'explique par l'histoire
et qu'il faut essayer de corriger
uniquement par l'histoire
je veux pas faire une bulle je vois
aussi très heureuse et je pense que
chacun a la volonté je prends de
d'essayer de rapprocher les deux mieux
répartir les logements sociaux
mais ce que ce que j'appelle le problème
qui se pose est 50 années certainement
une problème de proportion de logement
social c'est un problème de logement de
course que vous avez bien de le dire sur
dix il ya un problème de parcours
résidentiel pour la population et saint
quentin
je suis un des mots exemple on est
arrivés dans les années 70 et 80 mais on
était six dans la maison on a eu deux
dents ce qui se passe c'est canon de
logements constants il ya moins moins
d'habitants donc saint-quentin quelques
unes vides plutôt réussi on est
satisfaits d'y habiter
mais il faut trouver un nouvel élan
puisque aujourd'hui chaque année il ya
des gens qui arrivent des gens qui
partent mais à 2000 personnes de plus
qui partent que de gens qui arrivent et
ça c'est quand même pas bon pour le
dynamisme de la ville et ceux qui
partent sont plutôt des jeunes dont il
ya un effort de logements affaires
générales sur toute la gamme social où
ce n'est pas uniquement un problème de
logement social c'est lorsque la crise
moi je voudrais parler de solidarité
nouvelles pour le logement qui est une
association de bénévoles qui a comme
objectif d'acheter des logements sociaux
pour les attribuer à des personnes en
grande difficulté
donc nous sommes répartis sur la réserve
la place de l'état dans votre
association
pourquoi pas j'ai envie de dire qu'il
faut que chacun doit faire des efforts
l'état doit en fait un pli nous aussi et
je pense alors nous ya cinq départements
en france pas en france dans la région
ile de france 75 92 de 91 2 94 et 78 78
représente à peu près 200 logements
oui on a construit on a au nom s'est pas
construit justement je devrais je
voudrais revenir sur votre question
vous dites faut-il obliger des mers
accurso pas obligés de construire y
pauvres il faut répartir ces logements
dans la population
sinon si on construit un immeuble qui
est que des logements sociaux
ça devient de monde y met par contre de
répartir parmi des tout le monde oui ça
c'est valable et nous c'est ce que nous
faisons nous acheter ensuite voulait
voilà il ya une relation plutôt avoir
pour les personnes en difficulté
vous rencontrez des difficultés avec des
municipalités ou oui les terrains pour
ces problèmes les lois si vous voulez
tout loi peut être contournée donc j'ai
l'impression que certains certaines
municipalités apprécier les
contournements comme que moi qui
apprécient les contournements niveau des
impôts par exemple et je vois que on
avait
un immeuble a acheté quelque part dans
l'une des des communes qui nous entoure
et là comme par hasard le maire a refusé
parce qu'on n'avait pas c'est de parking
dans la rue rapport à cet immeuble qui
nous permettait de faire cinq logements
passé de parking est pour vous la vraie
raison mais quelle est la vraie raison
pour vous ben je refuse je pense que
c'est parce que je venais pas 3 rajouter
dans sa commune qui en avait déjà
beaucoup mais je vais dire que de
contourner la loi c'est très ennuyeux
parce que très souvent c'est comme ça
que ça se passe
l'équateur du web vous pariez du
programme de valérie pécresse je pense
que on a vu tout à l'heure l'infographie
c'est qu'il y à des villes comme la
verrière où trappe
on a plus de 60 70 % donc nous donc on
compterait effectivement des ghettos il
ya aucune utilité sociale donc la
position de la grèce et que la région ne
se souviendra de subventionnera pas les
communes qui sont au-delà de 30% parce
qu' il faut avoir une meilleure
répartition sur le territoire
quand on voit qu'il ya quand même 16
communes en yvelines qui représente plus
de 50% qui ont plus de 50 % de logements
sociaux donc donc on était que valérie
pécresse ne subventionnera pas pour
justement que cv ne puisse pas qu'on
continue pas à additionner du ghetto sur
du ghetto si vous êtes donc voilà donc
il faut favoriser l'accès à la propriété
de trois mesures quand même qu'ils sont
amis qui me semble important de décliner
il faut permettre l'accès à la propriété
en fait on constate qu'il ya une demande
de plus de 50 % des logements sociaux
ces dix dernières années et il y as en
2007 plus de 50 % des franciliens
étaient propriétaires aujourd'hui ses 40
5,6 pour cent
donc la crise économique aussi est
passée par là mais il faut favoriser
l'accession à la propriété est une des
possibilités ce sera de donner à prêt à
taux zéro pour aider les classes
moyennes à devenu propriétaire en tout
cas pour les primo accédants accédants
pendant donc c'est vraiment des choses
qui sont importantes pour répartir et
ensuite trouver un équilibre sur les
territoires en préservant aussi les
zones rurales qui sont les espaces verts
qui sont absolument clé mais ne pas
faire de l'entassement et des grandes
barques ou ensuite le vivre ensemble
quand doyen terme à la mode
mais n'est pas n'est pas le mot je veux
en profiter effectivement pour vous
montrer quelques photos
si on peut les montrer à l'écran c'est
que quand on parle d'entassement
effectivement pendant des années on
avait un pacte social qui était plutôt
intéressant parce qu'on avait la mixité
à l'époque donc on était plutôt dans un
cadre où même si c'était une grande
barre on y retrouvait des classes moyens
etc
vous savez très bien que le parc avis
que classes moyennes ont quitté
progressivement l'ensemble du territoire
et l'objectif de trappes à l'heure
actuelle c'est exactement pour ne pas
caricaturer l'un reste que ce que dit
madame pécresse à dire que nous sommes
en train de faire en sorte que cette
ville soit une ville comme les autres
donc là on retrouve effectivement d
ensemble du parc social tel qu'il était
avant très chargé fait pas encore mature
elle retrouve la léo lagrange avait même
procédé
demain rénover une ville qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que y ait pas
de stigmatisation territoriales quand
vous avez une ville comme trappe qui a
effectivement un tiers du parc social de
saint quentin en yvelines qui a un
besoin de rénovation parce que c'est un
peu datés voilà à quoi ça ressemble une
fois la rénovation faite hier qu'on
retrouve le charme des villes c'est vers
ça qu'on veut tendre donc quand on a 70
% de logements sociaux
on a beaucoup de rénovations à faire
lorsque dévala pécresse c'est à ils ont
plus de 30 % de logements sociaux
je vais pas les financer est-ce que
finances est venu aider les communes où
on est très en dessous des 30% que là où
on est très très au dessus c'est assez
logique et des lettres à répartir
l'effort sur le territoire mais ces
idées des communes excusez moi qui là où
c'est possible là où j'ai ensuite cessé
et des communes qui ont un langage
séduisant de d'augmenter de dogmatisme
au sujet des logements sociaux on le
sait très bien de ces politiques ce
n'est pas qu'une question de logement
social d'ailleurs le terme logement
social renvoi fausse réalité parce que
70% des français étant éligible on peut
parler un peu plus à mon avis d'achat
lèvres d'habitat à loyer modéré
c'est quand même l'objectif donc demain
la ville de trappes et comme d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des mères volontaires
l'idée c'est de construire de nouveaux
logements sociaux qui n'ont plus rien à
voir que les barres hlm des années 60 et
de maintenir que c'est une réalité en
france même de maintenir une mixité et
pour ça il comme très important si on
veut casser les ghettos dans nos villes
et je vais aller plus loin on pas de
ghetto souvent déshéritée
moi je parle de ghettos de riches on a
des ghettos de riches qui se soustrait à
la réalité de leur propre jeunesse parce
que vous êtes des jeunes qui ne peuvent
pas se reloger au sein de leur ville
deux des personnes âgées qui ne peuvent
plus supporter le coût des loyers et
donc par dogmatisme on va tourner le dos
à cette réalité de 70 % prennent aux
sauvages se devait donc sur dix la
vienne rappeler fixe mois tout le
travail fait à trois places depuis une
dizaine d'années on a parlé de la
verrière la verrière un projet alors
c'est à venir mais un projet très
important de construction d'un nouveau
quartier et drainage mans 2-2 du
quartier autour de la gare qui a
justement pour but de rééquilibrer les
proportions de logements et d'avoir
quelque chose de beaucoup plus des
rayons où on retrouve toute la gamme de
logements là puisque l'objectif c'est ce
que nous disons que d'esquissés c'est
d'avoir d'offrir dans un quartier toute
la gamme des logements alors vous avez
parlé semble tellement important de
renoncer à 72 pour sauver mais il va
prendre combien de temps 30 ans 40 ans a
réussi le but c'est pas trois des cinq
as 25e dans les nouveaux quartiers
seront équilibrés ce que je veux dire là
le et puis vous avez parlé du foncier
dans depuis ce qu'on a 50 ans divine
c'est sûr que quand on a fait la ville
nouvelle
on a construit sur du terrain agricole
aujourd'hui il faut regarder les photos
aériennes de la vie dont on s'aperçoit
que il ya certaines zones en partie des
zones d'activités où il ya beaucoup de
vide entre les immeubles et donc dans
les vingt ou trente ans il faut
restructurer sur tous ses autres
activités qui vieillissent et qui
peuvent toutes nos occasions près d'une
gare qui peuvent dans l'avenir c'est une
potentielle urbains importants pour
refaire d'evry katie cassidy ville ce
qui montre que 51 des sondés satisfaits
mais ce qui manque à 50 a surtout pour
les gens qui viennent y travailler dans
les zones d'activités sont coupés de la
ville et des gens qui viennent y
travailler
il voit pas de ville à saint quentin
donc il faut recréer des noyaux urbains
qui ressemblent à des villes des rues on
a envie de se promener
mireille brésil et d'ailleurs je vous
j'en profite pour vous posez peut-être
la dernière question de l'émission est
ce que la méthode
du gouvernement fait actuel et la bonne
c'est à dire qu'on parle pour les mères
réfractaires et qui ne respecteraient
pas ce pourcentage de 25%
on parle de préempter c'est à dire deux
doigts de prendre des des terrains de
force et de faire construire de s'unir à
lui choisi lens je donnerai la wii chez
moi je suis tout à fait d'accord pour la
préemption
le problème si vous voulez c'est que ça
va pas résoudre le problème de la
diversité des personnes qui sont à
reloger des personnes qui gagnent qui
vont payer un loyer à moins de 6 euros
le mètre carré
comment voulez vous que ces gens là
puissent vivre au milieu de personnes
qui vont payer 3000 4000 euros le mètre
carré
c'est pas possible donc est-ce que c'est
pas ça justement la mixité sociale des
six à la mixité sociale
mais comment faire pour que des maires
adhèrent à ce projet là c'est là que je
ne sais pas je pense qu'on est tous
d'accord sur le fait qu'il faut relancer
la construction il ya des besoins qui
sont énormes de qu il faut y répondre
mais il faut répondre de manière
pragmatique c'est à dire que on ne veut
pas faire des ghettos là où il donna
déjà il faut apaiser les choses et
apparaît construction qui permettent aux
gens de vivre heureux l'homme y sont
c'est vrai le plus important pensez au
financement des communes et des souvent
si les communes ne le font pas c'est
qu'elles n'ont pas la possibilité donc
il ya des silences derrière financière
oui mais aussi des systèmes de rétorsion
qui existe en fait une sorte de cagnotte
obligatoire pense qu'il faut aussi
donner du temps au temps pour que les
choses se passent parfois vous attendez
un centre-ville ne pouvait pas tout
détruire
c'est il faut avoir une approche qui
soit très pragmatique et envisager ça
sur des programmes pluriannuels
en tout cas la brutalité du gouvernement
déjà sur ce type de jeu ne conviendrait
pas il faut avoir une approche souple
la preuve son plan mardi pour conclure
oui alors non moi je suis plutôt dans
une approche un peu plus direct alors
juste pour redire en fait on est
mandatée en tant qu élu par suffrage
universel à ce titre on doit respecter
la loi
ça on peut pas en démordre la seconde
chose c'est qu'ils une position ferme du
gouvernement effectivement les préfets
ont maintenant dorénavant le pouvoir de
préemption des terrains situés dans les
villes qui ne jouent pas le jeu c'est ça
aussi le but je vous rappelle juste que
l'état a promis d'accompagner ces
communes dans le cadre de contrat de
mixité sociale
donc ça veut dire qu'on va prendre la
mesure
du démarrage tardif de telle ou telle
ville
par contre on va les accompagner et
quand je vois par exemple à magny les
hameaux comment bertrand ou lyon est en
difficulté pour la création de 30
logements sociaux mais j'ai bien peur
que le langage dogmatique les ans
portait déjà sur les rails rapidement
alors parce que simplement on imagine
qu'on va y mettre effectivement de 4,9
et sociales défavorisées et que ça ne va
pas créer la mixité en fait
effectivement et je rejoins tout à fait
ce que dit le snl à ce niveau là c'est
qu'il faut absolument permettre une
hétérogénéité sur l'ensemble du
territoire de saint quentin divine je
rappelle que sur les yvelines on a quand
même 45 mille demandeurs de logements
sociaux actuellement
donc c'est un peu urgent voilà si on
pouvait enfin se sent mauvais t1 34,8 %
de logements sociaux à manier les mots
de conclusion à bruno sauvage comme
atouar comolli de départ le jeu d'airé
de la question que vous nous posez les
valable sans doute d'autres communes
mais ça quand on est gay ne se sent pas
prêt visé directement par cette question
là nul mais c'est cette question
effectivement de trouver un rythme de
construction de logements et qui dit
prix en offrant toute la gamme entre
loger des cadres d'entreprises et puis
deux et puis ils répondent aux besoins
de logement social et surtout problème
de 50 à ces deux c'est de trouver le
nouveau départ pour la construction
c'est une ville nouvelle cabot
construite jusqu'en 2000 mais depuis ça
s'est ralenti et vous trouvez ce nouveau
départ avec d'une nouvelle formule qui
séduit plus de s'étaler il s'agit de
cogefi culte à leurs devoirs certains
quartiers qui peuvent changer
mercredi le sera la fin mais je voulais
dire tu voudrais dire que l'association
sur les sur la région ile-de-france à
1000 logements répartis dans la
population
mid sur ces 1000 logements si vous
voulez il y en a on se sent bien à
miliana
huit mille personnes qui ont été
accueillies dans des hlm depuis la
création du site depuis la création du
slm très bien et on a 11 cents bénévoles
qui les accompagnent
je rappelle qu'on peut retrouver toutes
vos actualités sur le site snl ti
réunion points aura nationale qui
réunion trois orgues
merci à tous les cinq d'avoir participé
à ce débat oui ça passe très vite débat
passionnant merci en tout cas d'avoir
participé à ce débat on se retrouve nous
dans trois semaines
mardi prochain et mardi dans deux
semaines c'est wilfried richy qui
animera le 7-8 politique
bonne soirée à tous